Let's discuss the political rights of
the woman in Islam.
The same verse I quoted earlier of surah
chapter number 9 verse number 71.
Well
the believing men and the woman they are
supporters unto one another. That means
not only socially they will support each
other politically.
Allah says in surah mtahina chapter
number 60 verse number 12. Oh prophet
when the woman come to thee with oath of
filty that means when the woman come to
give maya to the prophet politically as
though accepting him not only as a
leader of the community even the
messenger of god that means even the
woman can vote
the woman are giving the oath of fy to
the prophet far higher than voting in
the modern system
there's incident which is mentioned that
once when may peace with him were
discussing regarding should the women
were demanding too much mah. [laughter]
So he was discussing that should you put
upper limit for the mah. So a woman from
the back seat
back seat that means a normal woman even
the name is not mentioned in
she objects and says who is umar to put
the upper limit when Allah is not a put
upper limit. Allah says in the Quran is
you can even give a mountain of gold in
mah. So who is Omar to go to parliament?
Omar says Omar is wrong and the woman is
right. That means the woman took an
objection to the breach of constitution.
Quran is the constitution a normal woman
objecting to the khalifa. Who are you?
When Allah said in the Quran you can
give a mountain of gold in who is Omar
to put up limit. Omar says Omar is
wrong.
The woman is right.
So this was in brief regarding
the political rights
and women even took part in
battlefields. There's a full chapter
inside Bkari that women taking part in
battlefields. They act like nurses. They
give water to the Sabas.
And there's a specific incident when
there were few people who protect the
prophet when he was in danger. One of
them was a lady by the name of Nasiba.
And while protecting the prophet, she
fearlessly protected the prophet and got
injuries and wounds and the prophet
craved her for her bravery.
Imagine a woman
protecting the prophet.
So in Islam,
this was in brief regarding the
political rights of the women in Islam.
In Islam, men and women are equal but
equality doesn't mean identicality.
Let me give you an example
in the conclusion
that if there are many students who
appearing for an examination and in that
examination student A and B both of them
get 80 out of 100. When we analyze the
question paper and the answer paper we
realize there are 10 questions each
carrying 10 marks.
In answer to question number one,
student A gets
80 out of 100. So student A gets 90 out
of 100 and student B gets 70 out of 100.
In answer to question number two,
student A gets 70 out of 100 and student
B gets 90 out of 100. In all the
remaining eight answers, both of them
get 80 out of 100. Or if the question
mark is on 100 marks.
If the question full examination 100
marks, student A in answer to question
number one gets 9 out of 10. Student B
gets 7 out of 10. In answer to question
number two, student A gets seven out of
10. Student B gets 9 out of 10. In all
the remaining eight answers, both of
them get 8 out of 10. If you add up,
both get 80 out of 100. So student A and
student B overall are equal. But in
answer to question number one, student A
has the degree of advantage because he
gets 9 out of 10. Student B gets 10 out
of 10. In answer to question two,
student B has the degree of advantage
because he gets 9 out of 10. Student A
gets 10 out of 10. But overall both are
equal. So similarly in Islam, men and
women are equal. But in some aspects the
men have a degree of advantage. Some
aspects women have a degree of
advantage. For example, if a robber
enters my house, if a thief enters my
house, I'll not say I believe in women's
right. I'll not tell my wife to go and
fight. I'll not tell my daughter to go
and fight because Allah says in 4:34,
Allah has given more strength to one to
the man. So I have a degree of advantage
in strength. So if a thief comes, I will
go and fight. I'll not tell my wife or
my daughter to go and fight.